on est comment sur le bilan je viens je
pense qu'on est arrivé il est comptable
dans le film bénabar ouais c'est toi
conte à villecomtal et à thébaux ce qui
fait un
en fait j'ai confondu avec le arrivée la
comptable j'ai mis une demi heure pour
savoir que c'était toi enfin de vraies
elles réellement pour savoir que c'était
toi le comptable etc qui confondu avec
un autre acteur et j'ai mis du temps
avant de rendre compte que c'est
vraiment bénabar le chanteur qui jouait
dans le film merci oui
ouais ouais au bout d'une demi heure
dans le bureau parce que tu fus mais la
clope tout ça je le connais ce mec là
est aigri mais j'ai fait grimer dans le
sens est ouest
c'est incroyable en tout cas ils
travaillent
[Applaudissements]
vient de toi tu as aimé le film
j'ai eu honte parce qu'au départ j'ai
trouvé ça simple je suis habitué à des
choses en fait sur de l'action et tout
ça au bout d'une demi heure j'étais
comme ce film de cassavettes ce
bookmaker jeune oie nantas dure une demi
heure il n'y a rien qui se passe un qui
veut m'emmener où on veut tellement
menée et ensuite j'ai compris l'écriture
le style le jeu 12 à l'hélice est simple
attendu un bout de quelques bouts de
quel moment dernière demi heure j'ai en
fait vraiment j'ai eu je me suis trouvée
pas c'est normal je me suis non c'est
bien tu es tout ce qu'elle peut dans ce
cas il est beau ça oui merci savait pas
alors à mais lui c'est le jean de la
fontaine de donc ouais mais c'est le
jean de la fontaine mais il a bu la
fontaine
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais merci alors oui c'est bon je
t'appelle tout à l'heure on s'appelle
tout à l'heure non mais c'est vrai les
coiffeurs et tous les médias
il aide les gens et au bout de combien
de temps tu as compris 30 minutes et lui
ouais deux mineurs merara merci tu n'es
pas quoi faire mais il est fautif paula
haddad ya côté là je dis au langage des
chauffeurs livreurs
on sait pas ce qu'il fait là c'est un
pote à moi c'est tout il est donc là
mais dans deux minutes il va livrer de
la limonade
l'autre belle ça fait 8 a fait 80 lanka
n'a pas dormi